Many people think that criminal cases,
including death pony cases are won and lost,
won or lost in the selection of the jury.
Today we'll talk about how a person goes from their home in the community,
gets that summons in the mail,
telling them they've got a report for jury duty and ends up being one of 12
people sitting in a capital case deciding whether a person will live or die.
Uh,
actually,
jury selection is not so much selection as it is excluding people,
excluding people who can't be fair and impartial.
The parties exclude people with their peremptory strikes.
Uh,
and finally,
when all the dust clears,
their 12 people left and usually two alternatives.
Uh,
and those are the people who decide the case.
Let's look here quickly at how people go.
Uh,
as I said,
from their home to the jury,
where there one of 12 people sitting in the jury box,
uh,
we start with whatever the political subdivision is.
And uh,
many jurisdictions,
it's a county.
In Louisiana,
it's a parish or maybe a district.
If it's federal court,
it will be a United States federal district.
But those are divided into divisions.
Usually.
Uh,
in some states,
a jury commission will make the determination that out of the people in that
county,
let's say,
uh,
which ones will be included in the jury pool,
other places,
it may be done just by computer.
Uh,
but not everybody who lives in the community will necessarily be in the jury
pool.
And this is what the litigation has been about with regard to whether or not
jury juries are,
are representative or whether there's been discrimination in the selection of
the juries.
Uh,
there's no right to have a jury here,
the 12 people to decide the case.
No right to have a jury,
uh,
that reflects the composition of the community.
But the jury pool must represent roughly the composition of the jury.
In other words,
if the community is 25% African American and they're only 10% African American
Americans in the jury pool,
uh,
that's a 15% underrepresentation.
And that would be the basis for a challenge to the jury pool saying that it
needs to be reconstituted so that it better represents the entire community.
By the same token,
uh,
the jury pool,
we look at race,
ethnicity,
and also gender.
We would assume that jury pool and most communities are going to be about 50,
50 men and women.
If we see the jury pool has only 30% women,
uh,
then there's obviously a problem with that and there are two legal basis for
challenging it.
One that has been discrimination,
a violation of the equal protection clause in excluding that group,
either by race or by gender.
Uh,
secondly,
uh,
that there's been a denial of the sixth amendment guarantee of the fair cross
section of the community.
And either way,
uh,
a court will look at what the composition has been over some period of time,
how the selection process works.
Uh,
how subjective it is a,
whether there's some explanation for the disparity,
but otherwise,
uh,
the,
jury will have to be reconstituted so that it more fairly,
uh,
reflects the community out of the jury pool.
A number of people will be summoned to the courthouse for trials.
They'll get a summons in the mail telling him to come to court.
Uh,
and then once they get to the courthouse,
they'll usually go to a jury assembly room,
unless it's a very small community where they may go straight to the courtroom
and a group of people will be called what we call the veneer.
A group of people will be called to the courtroom for questioning.
And this is the start of the jury selection process.
The first thing is why they're the questioning of the jurors,
uh,
which may be by the judge maybe by the parties,
but as that questioning has gone on,
or at the end of it,
uh,
each party will be able to strike a certain number of jurors for cause that is
a,
okay,
oh,
I screwed that up.
Let me back up on,
okay.
The people call to the courtroom,
uh,
we call this the,
the near,
these are the people that are going to be summons to the courtroom.
And now we're going to be questioning question.
This is what the jury process involves,
what we call for deer,
the questioning of the jurors.
And while the jurors are being questioned,
one of the things the parties and the court will be looking for is whether
there's any reason the juror can't be fair and impartial and the judge can
strike any juror for cause.
Uh,
if they can't,
if that juror cannot be fair and impartial,
uh,
ultimately,
each side will exercise peremptory strikes,
which we'll talk about another time.
Uh,
each side will have a certain number of strikes,
a established,
usually by a state statute or rule.
Uh,
and once,
uh,
they strike down.
We'll have usually a jury of 12 jurors and two alternates.
If the case is expected to last a really long time,
uh,
there may be four alternatives.
The alternatives of course would substitute for the jurors if for some reason a
juror had a family emergency or,
uh,
I had a personal emergency or something like that and had to be replaced.
Uh,
the questioning of jurors,
that method is decided,
uh,
pretty much by the judge.
Uh,
and also to some extent by statute or rule.
it differs from questioning each teacher individually.
Uh,
that is in Texas.
A jury may take a jury selection,
may take a long time while each juror is brought in,
one at a time,
ask questions by the prosecution,
by the defense.
Uh,
and then another jurors is brought in.
You can imagine that takes some period of time,
uh,
in other judges will conduct the jury selection and panels.
That is,
they'll bring a group of 12 or 13 people or 15 in at one time.
And just those people will be questioned.
And some of the questions will be group questions to everyone.
Like,
raise your hand if you know someone involved in this case.
Uh,
and some will be individual cases like Mr. Smith.
I see here on your jury questionnaire,
uh,
that you work at a certain place.
Would that,
uh,
in any way come into play if you were chosen as a juror.
So,
uh,
that's another way to do it.
And then a third way is often,
and this is particularly true in federal courts,
all the jurors maybe question in one huge group.
In other words,
the court room is full of prospective jurors.
And,
uh,
whether the questioning is done by the judge or by the lawyers is again,
often differs from judge to judge in court.
The court,
uh,
in many federal courts,
the judge will conduct the jury selection,
which will only take a very short period of time.
Uh,
the judge will tell the jurors about the case,
ask them if there's any reason they can't be fair and impartial,
ask a few other questions.
Uh,
the jurors are to respond by raising their hand.
If the answer is yes to those questions,
but most people won't say anything.
And so the actual striking of the jury,
uh,
will take place without either side knowing very much about those jurors.
If we're in a place that has a large population,
of course,
if we're in a small jurisdiction,
uh,
it may very well be that everybody knows everybody,
that the prosecutor through the sheriff's Deputies and other people,
uh,
knows,
about all the jurors if not notice them.
In fact,
and by the same token,
the defense may very well know the people.
The other point I'd make here is that what the jury is going to look like,
it's going to depend very much upon the county or the parish from which the jury
is chosen.
Uh,
if you have a white flight suburban community that is a community in which
they're almost no people of color,
95% white population,
then the jurors who are some of the courtroom are probably going to be about 95%
white.
Uh,
and so the likelihood that they're going to be any people of color on that jury
is,
is pretty slim.
On the other hand,
if you're in a more diverse community,
uh,
where a third of the population is African American,
then you should see that reflected in the g in the jurors who are summoned to
court.
Um,
and then the question for strikes for cause it's basically can juror be fair and
impartial on any subject?
I'm going to talk about the three that come up the most.
Uh,
but there can be others as well.
Has the juror heard about the case?
In a lot of cases where there's been a lot of media attention to the case,
a lot of social media attention,
a lot of talking about the case in small communities.
Uh,
one of the concerns is going to be,
uh,
to the jurors already had their minds made up,
because of what they've read or what they've seen about the case.
Uh,
secondly,
less often asked,
but I want to be sure to touch on it is racial bias to the jurors have any
racial prejudice which might come into play,
particularly if it's white jurors and they're sitting on an interracial crime.
Supreme Court has recognized the right to ask questions about that.
And then third,
uh,
what are the jurors attitudes on the death penalty?
Uh,
because it may be that some people either feel so strongly in favor of the
death,
Polly,
uh,
that they can't be fair and impartial or there may be and probably will be more
people,
uh,
who for religious conscientious or other reasons are opposed to the death Polly
and wouldn't consider the death pony any under any circumstances.
Uh,
those people,
uh,
will probably be excluded unless they're able to put those fears aside.
Same thing with pretrial publicity.
The question will be,
you've heard about the case,
you've read about it and maybe you've talked about it,
but can you put that aside and decided the case just on the evidence that you
hear in court.
Um,
and then once those strikes a,
once the court has decided who struck for cause,
uh,
each side exercises a certain number of peremptory strikes the prosecution and
the defense,
uh,
for a long time,
you could exercise a preemptive strike for any reason and you didn't have to
give a reason.
The parties did not.
Uh,
but now,
uh,
a party cannot strike based on race or gender,
unless there is a race or gender neutral reason for it.
And we'll talk more about that in another segment.
Uh,
but whether that works or not is certainly subject to debate.
And again,
the method of,
of,
of striking jurors may vary a judge by judge court,
by court and courts where the jurors are examined one at a time.
It may be that right after each juror is questioned a party exercise of
peremptory strike.
Of course,
it's hard to do that because you don't know what all the other jurors look like.
Uh,
in courts that question,
people in panels,
it may be that after each panel,
let's say 12 is questioned,
each side goes in chambers with the judge out of the presence of the jury.
And each side makes its motions to strike for cause.
I don't think that person can be fair because of what they read about the case,
the judge grants or denies,
then the judge may call upon the parties to exercise their peremptory strikes.
In other words,
each side may have 10 strikes.
And so right then the judgment call upon a party saying,
uh,
the you accept these people or,
or do you strike or a what is at least,
uh,
often done and majors dictions issue qualify the number of people you need to
choose the jury.
Uh,
so for example,
if each side had 10 strikes plus two strikes for an alternate,
uh,
you'd qualify 38 people and then each side would exercise 12 strikes.
And that will leave you with a jury of 12 and two alternates.
So all of these,
uh,
methods of jury selection differ.
When other thing I should say is that very often,
not only is that the questioning of the jurors,
but judges,
uh,
often allow a jury questionnaire,
to be circulated.
Some jury questionnaires,
a very extensive,
they may go on for 15 or 20 pages.
Some jury questionnaires may be two pages.
So again,
the discretion of the judge,
how the judge allows this process to take place.
Uh,
and some jury selection process is very elaborate with long questionnaires,
individual questioning of jurors in other places.
And this is in capital cases as well as non capital cases.
Uh,
the jury selection may be very perfunctory as it was in the [inaudible] case,
which we will,
we'll,
we'll talk about,
uh,
because the question comes,
what,
what can you ask,
what can a party,
let's say a person represented representing men and his case in Virginia?
Uh,
what can you ask the jurors?
he was,
uh,
accused of a murder a while he was in a prison work crew.
Uh,
47 newspaper articles.
not only did they tell about the murderer who was accused hub and an earlier
murder he had been involved in also told about his confession.
Uh,
said he had been rejected for parole six times.
So the defense had some reason to be concerned that if people had read these
things,
they might not be fair and impartial.
They might already think that he's guilty of the crime because they've got a lot
of publicity.
Uh,
the first thing a lawyer does in that situation for a person facing the death,
plenty is moved for a change of venue,
move the case to another county,
uh,
where people haven't heard anything about the case and have a very,
you know,
don't bring any of this knowledge into the jury box.
Seldom is a change of venue.
Granted,
partly with elected judges,
it's a politically,
uh,
often not a good idea to move the,
the,
the trial out of the community where people want to decide both guilt and
punishment.
Uh,
and what judges will often do is what happened in the movement in case the
Virginia judge there said,
well,
we'll question the jurors and then we will see,
uh,
whether or not they can be fair and impartial if they can,
we'll have the trial here.
Uh,
if they can't,
then we'll,
we'll change the venue.
Uh,
so,
uh,
once the change of venue was denied,
a moment wanted or his lawyers,
uh,
wanted the judges to ask questions about what the jurors had seen about the case
read,
heard about the case,
so called content questions.
Of course,
if you do that in a group,
it doesn't work.
Because if one person stands up and says,
well,
I heard he confessed to the crime and goes into some detail in describing it,
then all the other jurors hear it.
So you have to pretty much do that,
uh,
one at a time.
Uh,
but in this case,
the judge just simply question all the jurors as a group and would not ask about
what they had read or heard,
just simply as,
can you keep an open mind?
Can you wait until the case is presented?
Uh,
before reaching a decision about guilt or innocence.
and so some people were struck when they answered those questions.
Uh,
and then each side struck six jurors,
14 people were seated,
12 jurors and 12,
two alternates.
So moments case makes it all the way to the United States Supreme Court.
On the question of did he have an adequate opportunity to get a fair jury
because he wasn't allowed to ask these questions.
Uh,
and here,
Justice Rehnquist rights for the court on a very close call,
five to four opinion by the Supreme Court and says that the content questions
are not constitutionally required.
He points out that if you had the content questions,
you'd have to ask each teacher individually and for this court,
uh,
saving time,
what's most expeditious,
very important consideration.
Uh,
and then secondly,
the wide discretion that judges have and all of these areas that the judge has a
lot of discretion in how to conduct a jury selection.
And if the judge wants to do it in a big group,
they can,
uh,
but that the constitution at least doesn't reach this far.
And Sandra Day O'connor writes a concurring opinion.
She was the swing vote,
uh,
in this case.
Uh,
and she said it would have been helpful had the jurors answer these questions.
It certainly would have been more,
uh,
the judge would have been better able to make decisions about how fair and
impartial jurors could be if the judge knew what the answers to the questions
were,
what they had read,
and what they had heard.
But she said the constitution doesn't require that the sixth amendment doesn't
require that.
And here we see what we see from time to time.
The court says,
here's what the constitutional floor is.
You at least got to do whatever.
But if a state wants to,
if a judge wants to ask more questions,
justice O'Connor saying,
who'd be good?
I did ask more questions,
but it's not required by the constitution.
So she,
uh,
is the fifth vote here,
which now means that juries can be selected in any jurisdiction in sort of the
very superficial way,
uh,
that the jury was selected.
In this case,
a Justice Marshall to sense.
He points out that the assurances of jurors,
this,
this system basically lets the jurors decide whether they can be fair and
impartial as opposed to a judge hearing everything a juror knows about a case,
what opinions they may have formed,
what conversations they may have had with their spouse or their children,
their neighbors.
Uh,
and then the judge makes a decision that even though this person thinks he or
she may be fair and impartial,
perhaps they know a little too much,
or perhaps they've set a little too much.
If they've said,
you know,
they ought to hang that guy.
Uh,
if you knew that a judge might make a different decision,
if you just ask a person to on Moss,
raise your hand if you're not able to be fair and impartial.
Uh,
not many hands are going to be raised.
Justice Kennedy,
who's using the swing vote this time is a descending a writes a descending
opinion.
Uh,
and he said,
you just can't rely upon silence by jurors to questions as to the whole group
and Mohs.
Uh,
so it's a close decision,
uh,
but because of justice O'Connor's,
voting,
uh,
the way that she did,
the court upholds moomins jury selection process.
Um,
what about the racial attitudes of the jurors?
Uh,
several cases important,
uh,
to this.
I want to just touch on a couple lightly and then we'll talk about Turner versus
Marie and Ham versus South Carolina.
Uh,
the defendant ham wanted to ask questions about race and what the jurors,
racial attitudes,
where would you disregard his race if you were chosen as a juror?
And do you have any prejudice against black people?
Uh,
and have you used the term black,
which at the time of this case in 1973,
uh,
had not been used as much as of course,
it has been,
uh,
since that time,
the judge would not allow those questions and the Supreme Court held that that
was air and that ham was entitled to a new trial.
But it was because of the facts of the case.
Justice Rehnquist writes the opinion and he says,
in this case,
Hams,
whole defense was that he was being prosecuted because he was active in the
civil rights movement and he was,
uh,
the law enforcement agencies were out to get him,
because of his civil rights activities.
So issues of civil rights,
race,
we're front and center in this case.
And in this case,
he had a right under the due process clause to ask the court to ask the jurors
about their racial attitudes.
But then the court,
in another case,
just a few years later,
Christando versus Ross,
uh,
decides that that's not required in a case,
even though it was a case involving three African Americans charged with the
murder of a white person.
Uh,
the court said because race wasn't inextricably tied up in the case.
In fact,
the case was not about race,
it was just a,
a crime,
but it was black on white,
excuse me,
black on white,
that the defendants are black.
Uh,
the victim was white.
the Supreme Court had earlier said way back in 1931,
a in the Aldridge case,
uh,
the corn had said in response to some justices saying it'd be too much trouble
to ask these questions.
Uh,
the majority of the court had said it would be better to take the time to ask
these questions then had people speculate about how much race may have played a
role in the decision.
Well,
the court in Roe Stano decides that that's not a constitutional rule.
That's just a rule that the court adopted for lower federal courts as in it's
supervisory power over lower courts.
And so hell that,
uh,
the race questions weren't required,
in this case.
Now,
that doesn't mean that a trial judge might not ask those questions.
Uh,
but the court is saying they're not constitutionally required.
And then Willy Lloyd Turner's case comes along.
Uh,
this is a case again,
out of Virginia.
Murray was the warden or theirs.
It's the prison where Turner was held.
And Willie Lloyd Turner brought his case up on the grounds that the jurors in
his trial,
he had wanted to ask questions about their racial attitudes and wasn't allowed
to,
uh,
hear the Supreme Court says the questioning was required in Turner's case
because of it being an interracial case.
And secondly,
being a capital case,
uh,
the court pointed out the discretion that jurors have in capital sentencing that
basically,
unlike deciding whether a person meets the four elements of a crime,
uh,
there's a great deal of discretion,
in how jurors view mitigating evidence,
aggravating evidence,
victim impact evidence,
and make decisions in death penalty cases.
So there's a lot of discretion.
And then secondly,
uh,
jurors might,
in exercising that discretion be influenced by their racial attitudes and
according to even suggest that the jurors might be,
uh,
affected by their unconscious racial attitudes.
This is quite a,
a remarkable recognition on the part of the court because almost all the court
cases about race discrimination is about intentional race discrimination.
Here.
The court is not saying these jurors would intentionally discriminate,
but they're saying they may have attitudes,
they may have stereotypes,
they may be afraid of black people.
Uh,
they may have subtle biases that they don't even realize they have themselves.
and there's some chance that they would come into play.
So the court holds that had violated a Turner's,
a right to an impartial jury because of the unacceptable risk.
Not that racial bias was proven,
but the failure to ask the questions resulted in an unacceptable risk.
That race might play away,
uh,
play a role.
But the remedy the court gives us almost completely inadequate to do deal with
the problem of unconscious discrimination.
Uh,
the court says the judge has the discretion,
the jurors can be questioned individually or they can be questioned as a group.
Uh,
all they have to be told is that this is an interracial crime.
As you can see,
ladies and gentlemen,
the gentleman sitting at counsel table,
it's an African American.
Uh,
I'm telling you that the victim in this case was white or Caucasian.
would any of you have any racial bias that would come into play if you were
chosen to sit on this case?
Of course,
almost no one is going to raise their hand and answer to that question.
So,
uh,
the courts can do very little,
in response to Turner.
Also,
these questions are asked only if the defense lawyer asks for them.
Uh,
otherwise,
uh,
it's waived.
But some courts will grant questioning and we'll grind questioning individually
of jurors about racial attitudes in which there are opportunities to really
engage jurors about congress in conversations about race.
What do they think of the segregated schools,
the all white,
uh,
segregation academy and do they send their children there?
Uh,
what do they think about whatever the racial attitudes in the community are?
do they think that the defendant has anything to worry about,
uh,
with regard to race in this community?
Not what they personally think.
But in the community it's possible to have a conversation.
And out of that conversation,
the lawyers can get some sense of what the jurors attitudes are with regard to
rates.
Uh,
some jurors will be fairly open about it.
some jurors will be very,
uh,
closed and,
and,
uh,
almost unwilling to talk about it.
Uh,
those things tell lawyers things,
uh,
that they may use when they make strikes of the jurors.
Uh,
later on in Turner's case,
the Supreme Court upheld his conviction,
uh,
but set aside his death sentence.
So the case was sent back,
uh,
just simply for a trial and sentence.
As it turned out,
Turner was as to death even,
uh,
when the questions were asked at his second trial and he was ultimately put to
death by the state of Virginia.
Um,
the next question is the jurors attitudes on the death penalty.
Uh,
this is usually something depending upon the community.
It's going to take a lot of time during jury selection.
I've been in communities where when you ask the question,
is anybody opposed to the death poly?
Uh,
not a single person says a word.
So there's no questioning to be done there,
at least on that part of it.
Uh,
but in many communities,
there will be a number of people who will have some religious or other scruples
against the death penalty.
But for the Witherspoon case was decided with a spoon versus Illinois in 1968.
Of course,
we're just simply ask people raise their hand if they were opposed to the death
poly and they would excuse them.
Uh,
but the Supreme Court,
uh,
decided that,
it shouldn't be that easy.
Uh,
and that,
that was excluding too many people in the community for jury service.
So,
uh,
they said two things set them both in footnotes.
Uh,
in this case,
the footnotes are more important than the written opinion.
Uh,
the courts said they,
that a jerk can't be excluded unless that juror states unambiguously that he or
she would automatically,
these became the critical words in jury selection for many years,
that the person would automatically vote against the death penalty.
Uh,
or if the jurors didn't make it unmistakably clear.
And what this meant was when an appellate court reviewed the case,
when the State Supreme Court or a federal court on a Habeas Corpus reviewed the
case,
it had to be unmistakably clear in the transcript of the jury selection that the
juror would automatically vote against the death penalty.
So what this meant is there wasn't the usual deference to trial judges.
And so for many years after the Witherspoon case was decided,
a lot of death penalty cases were set aside,
uh,
based upon,
people's,
uh,
answers to the questions about whether they could decide death pony cases or
not.
Uh,
Weatherspoon was decided two years after the Gallup poll has shown that for the
only time in the history of the United States,
more people were opposed to the death penalty than for it.
47% opposed 42% in favor.
Uh,
since that time,
uh,
support for the death penalty has gone up as high as 70%,
and then receded back to something much lower than that.
Uh,
but you can see in the court's opinion,
uh,
how it sees that the death pony is,
as it says,
uh,
on the way out.
Just as Stewart says,
a death qualified jury.
That is jurors who,
uh,
only made up of people who vote for the death.
Pawnee can speak for only a distinct and dwindling minority.
Uh,
the state has produced a jury that is uncommonly willing,
uh,
to,
condemn a person to die,
uh,
and that Illinois has stacked the deck.
This is very,
a descending opinions don't like this language at all that Illinois has stacked
the deck and given Mr Witherspoon a hanging jury.
Well,
justice is black.
Harlan and white,
uh,
are quite,
upset with that characterization of what's going on.
After all,
this is the way capital jurors had been selected all the way up until the time
Gr,
uh,
Wetherspoons jury was selected and actually until Wetherspoons case was before
the Supreme Court in 1968,
but it had quite an effect on who could serve on capital juries and who could
not.
And another,
unless it was unmistakably clear that the person would automatically vote
against the death pony.
In other words,
that the person,
you could say,
I would consider death probably wouldn't consider it very long,
but I would consider it.
It would be very hard to exclude that person.
Well,
the Supreme Court started changing that,
uh,
as a,
soon as it could first in a case out of Texas in 1980 called Adam sources Texas.
But that case sorta did not really get noticed.
The case that got noticed was Wainwright versus with a,
which was decided in 1985 and here the court did two things that are critically
important.
He changed the grounds for disqualification.
It no longer was whether it was automatically vote against the death penalty.
It was whether a person's views about the death pony would prevent or
substantially impair their ability to consider death as a punishment.
So that was a difference there.
The second difference,
even a bigger one,
the court replaced the requirement that the juror's ability to serve be
unmistakably clear and instead defers to the trial judge.
In other words.
Now,
instead of the appellate court,
looking at the transcript of the jury selection in saying it's not unmistakably
clear here,
that this juror cannot be fair and impartial because he or she will not consider
the death penalty is a punishment.
Uh,
now the court says once there's this back and forth between the maybe the judge
and the juror,
the parties,
the lawyers for each party and the jurors,
the judge at the end of that time says,
I'm striking this juror because I don't think he or she can be fair and
impartial because of their views on the death penalty.
Now,
appellate courts are going to defer to what the trial judge's did.
And not only that,
they're going to assume that the trial judge knew what the law was and applied
it correctly than in other words,
the trial judge knew what the law was and made a factual determination based on
the demeanor of the juror,
how the jury answer the questions,
all sorts of atmospherics that are seeing there in the courtroom but may not be
in an appellate record.
So this was a great change in two regards.
Uh,
with regard to death qualification and once wit versus Wainwright was decided,
fewer and fewer cases,
more,
uh,
was it unlikely that a case would be reversed based upon some person sitting on
the jury,
uh,
or being excluded from the jury?
That really is the issue that would go up as a,
uh,
the defense would object to striking.
The person in the state would say,
I moved to strike this juror because she can't fairly consider the death Polly
and the judge would grant that and that would be the issue on appeal.
And that became less and less of an appellate issue once Wainwright versus what
was decided,
uh,
the court decided a couple of other points with regard to the death on jurors
are what jurors could be as,
uh,
to lower federal courts had held that a desk qualification.
Uh,
they,
because you take off the jury,
all the people who are opposed to the death Pawnee or have scruples against it,
uh,
that you have a jury that is prosecution prone and you obviously have a jury
that's more likely to give the death penalty.
And those courts also had said that,
uh,
you don't have a fair cross section of the community when you've excluded that
part of the community that opposes the death penalty.
Well,
the Supreme Court reversed a case out of the eight circuit Lockhart versus
McCree reverse both cases.
The other case was out of the Fourth Circuit,
uh,
and said that death qualification does not deny a defendant a fair cross section
of the community.
Uh,
the fair cross section applies only to the veneer,
to the jury pool that we were talking about before.
Uh,
it,
and,
and secondly,
uh,
when we're talking about a fair cross section,
we're talking about the exclusion of race,
ethnicity,
gender,
uh,
but not people's attitudes on an issue.
Uh,
so,
uh,
people with,
opposition to the death penalty,
the court said are not,
uh,
a distinct group.
Uh,
the court then went on to look at the fact that,
well,
what about the fact that it's not a fair jury because it's so prosecution pro.
Uh,
and the court said that,
uh,
delve qualification was,
was not such a,
that it denied a person,
a fair trial.
And that it would be so cumbersome,
uh,
to select a jury try case and then qualify as the jurors about their attitudes
on the death pony and then try the penalty phase,
uh,
that it would be,
as the court said,
hopelessly impractical.
So again,
considerations of efficiency,
uh,
administration,
judicial economy,
uh,
are the determining a considerations here with the court and it rejected those
claims and uh,
they,
uh,
have not been heard since practicalities basically,
triumphed over this claim,
uh,
that the jurors can be fair and we're very prosecution prone and very likely to
impose death.
The other case it's important to mention is Morgan versus Illinois.
Here the case,
basically the court basically said,
uh,
that just as you can ask if a person is opposed to the death pony and therefore
will not consider imposing the death.
Polly,
uh,
you can also ask people whether they are so in favor of the death penalty for
certain crimes,
uh,
that they can consider a sentence of life imprisonment or life imprisonment
without parole.
And there will be jurors who will be excluded.
There'll be jurors who say,
if it's a police officer killing case,
see,
I think somebody that committed that crime should get the death pony.
And I don't think any other punishment is enough.
That person may be excluded for the same reason another person would be excluded
when that person said,
I'm religiously opposed to the death.
Polly,
uh,
I could consider life imprisonment,
but I could not ever vote for the death poem.
Uh,
in some jurisdictions,
jurors have three choices and sometimes even more,
uh,
death penalty,
life imprisonment without parole and life imprisonment with parole.
And sometimes jurors will say,
I could consider death.
I could consider life imprisonment without parole,
but I couldn't consider parole a sentence that would,
uh,
be,
parole eligible for this defendant given what he's accused of.
And those people may be excluded for that reason,
very much discretion on the part of the trial judge here and deciding how to
grant these motions to strike jurors.
Uh,
we get into the question of what does it mean to consider?
Because the person who's religiously opposed to the death pony,
for example,
will never consider the death penalty.
That person is opposed to the death poem.
Many African Americans are excluded,
uh,
during this death qualification process because they will say,
well,
I'm opposed to the death poem.
Uh,
it's been used to discriminate against black people throughout the history of
the United States.
And,
and I,
I think it should not be used anymore.
Uh,
and I would never vote to send anybody to death.
Well,
that person is excluded.
But then you have the person who says,
I strongly in favor of the death penalty.
I think the death penalty should be imposed in this kind of case.
I'm not sure any other punishment would really be adequate.
But the judge turns to the person and says,
well,
could you consider life without parole?
Yeah,
I could consider life without parole.
You have the sense that may be a rather fleeting consideration,
but this person has no religious objections to life without parole.
The person just simply doesn't think it's a,
it's a severe enough sentence,
but the person who is against the death penalty may have religious or other
reasons,
uh,
which would never allow them to vote for the death point.
So the result of this can often be that the jury is somewhat skewed with the
people who are opposed to the death pony all being excluded.
And with many people who have strong views in favor of the death,
Polly a remaining on the jury because they say they can consider the alternative
of life imprisonment without parole.
But one final case,
uh,
which takes us full circle on the death qualification and that Utec versus
Brown,
uh,
decided by the Supreme Court in 2007.
Uh,
the juror here was identified only as jurors z in the court's opinion.
It was a referee basketball referee.
His brother was a police officer.
So just based upon that,
uh,
you would think that he might not be a bad jury.
A juror for the prosecution.
Uh,
here's what's interesting about,
at least in my view,
that case,
one,
he was not,
he had no objections to the death.
Poland.
This was not like what we see often,
which is a juror takes the stand and judge says,
what's your opinion,
the death point and say,
I'm opposed to the death poem.
I have religious scruples against the death penalty.
A,
I can never impose.
This is Jared didn't impose the death pony,
uh,
didn't oppose the death by,
he had no problem with it,
but he was asking very kind of broad question,
when would the death pony be appropriate?
And he was very confused in his answers.
Uh,
any worried about that the person might be released,
even though he was told more than once about life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole.
Uh,
he,
he seemed not to completely understand it,
but he repeated,
uh,
I believe in the death penalty.
Uh,
the judge granted the strike,
the prosecution moved to strike the Juror for cause said that this juror
couldn't be fair and impartial,
uh,
because of his views about the death penalty.
Uh,
and that was upheld by the Supreme Court,
uh,
in this case.
So we've gone full circle from,
uh,
Weatherspoon where a jury had to make it unmistakably clear that their views
about the death pony were so strong that they would automatically vote against
the death point every case to utech versus Brown,
where the court says simply because the juror expresses some confusion,
uh,
and doesn't,
sometimes you see cases where the jerseys don't want to be involved in deciding
whether another person's going to live or die.
Uh,
and the trial judge excludes that person,
uh,
that's going to be sustained.
Uh,
so,
uh,
now very much the question of who sits on the jury given their attitudes about
the death pony is very much up to the trial judge that tries that case in very
seldom,
uh,
is the trial judge's decision on that,
going to be reversed by an appellate court because the trogers there sees the
jury.
This is going to be true in all of these areas.
How we conduct the voir dire,
what questions are asked,
and then the ultimate choice or decision that a trial judge makes in these
cases,
which is whether or not that juror can be fair and impartial,
uh,
parties may appeal it,
but there's going to be a lot of discretion given to the judge in those
situations.
And so that concludes our discussion of just a very basic overview,
uh,
of the jury selection process with regard to,
questioning jurors and determining if they can be fair and impartial.
Uh,
in another segment,
we'll turn to the use of the peremptory strikes in which the parties are able,
the prosecutor and the defense lawyer are able to strike people from jury
service.